have you got the the MTV camp thing
going yeah it's good how's it look okay
I wanna move with you we're outside at
the famous Kodak Theatre in Hollywood
California and a lot of people thought
the Berkeley video was unfair so we
wouldn't ask some fair questions some
current questions in regard to this
administration we want to see who knows
what hi do you think people gonna get
sick with the camera that looks cool
come in
who is the President of the United
States Barack Obama this is not a trick
question who is the vice president of
the United States that one dude
Harlem swordsman Arnold Schwarzenegger
it's a good guess oh I have no idea
go ahead but but dude I totally know
this i watch the news I know that I know
that I know that I know it
Dick Cheney no it's not it's not Dick
Cheney where are you from I'm from
America but I'm moving to London so
you're from America but you don't like
America no not really
so who is the English Prime Minister
some really ugly guy you have to
remember I designed a martini that's it
fine first name who is a Joe Biden Joe
Biden I heard his name
Joe bye
doesn't ring a bell who is Joe Biden the
secretary I don't know secretary enough
okay when I say Joe Biden who do you
think of who is Joe by the news I think
maybe yeah
not too many people seem to know our
vice president so we decided to change
things up this is Big Bear outside of
the Kodak Theater let's see if this
works
who is Angelina Jolie who is the Vice
President to the United State Hillary
Clinton no I don't know get out of the
frame you're in the frame you're in the
shot
we just said you didn't know that don't
ask us Dick Cheney
Dick Cheney I won't you better start
Biden Joe Biden Joe Budden Joe Biden
when I say the name Joe Biden what do
you think of I have no idea that versus
I don't know
nothing no no just
I say the name Joe Biden vice president
coming close to knowing Nancy Pelosi
[Music]